[Musica]
salve buonasera mi chiamo felix giuro è
il mio nome lecce la mia passione
la comunicazione la mia passione è la
comunicazione inevitabilmente perché la
comunicazione vita è una caratteristica
che appartiene alle persone vive fin
quando siamo vivi
comunichiamo sin da bambino ho avuto una
grande ammirazione per le persone che
comunicavano con una straordinaria
capacità di convincere di convincere
chiunque e quello che mi incuriosiva in
modo particolare era come facessero
semplicemente usando una facoltà che
adatta a tutte le persone come potessero
utilizzare la parola la voce ottenendo
però degli effetti diversi da quelli che
ottenevano le altre le altre persone mi
sono appassionato a tal punto che ho
iniziato a studiarla da me cercando di
osservare qual era la differenza tra i
vari comunicatori e mi sono accorto ad
esempio che una cosa che rendeva
particolarmente coinvolgente il modo di
parlare di alcuni era ad esempio che non
parlavano con inflessione dialettale che
non parlavano in dialetto e allora mi
sono chiesto ma è possibile rimanere se
stessi imparando a comunicare in maniera
diversa è la risposta è presto arrivata
è possibile è possibile imparare a
parlare
in maniera professionale rimanendo la
persona che sa parlare in dialetto
ovvero in italiano con inflessione
dialettale ecco e da lì è partita la mia
esplorazione per cercare di capire in
che modo poter padroneggiare di più la
comunicazione e allo stesso tempo in che
modo potevo aiutare altre persone a
usare meglio questo patrimonio che ha
dato a tutti a prescindere dal ceto
sociale dal genere di appartenenza anche
la persona più povera del mondo possiede
la facoltà della parola ha una voce ea
un corpo quando è fortunato di essere
sano che può utilizzare per trasmettere
informazioni era un ragazzo molto timido
e quindi mi sono chiesto come si può
superare questo ostacolo che è appunto
la paura di qualcosa che non una
materialità è una paura strana quella
che si prova quando si parla in pubblico
si ha paura di qualcosa che non si è
assolutamente in grado di toccare con
mano si ha paura del giudizio degli
altri
ecco facendo tutte queste riflessioni ho
fatto anche delle scoperte ho iniziato a
frequentare dei corsi di recitazione
teatrale di impostazione della voce
molti mi dicevano che che non sarei più
stato me stesso
e a volte con curiosità ma a volte
scherzando io chiedevo quale altra
persona sarei potuto diventare se
bastava così poco per diventare
qualcun'altro qualcos'altro in
osservando mi sono anche resoconto
facendo anche gli studi
universitari che purtroppo fatto il
ritardo perché in giovane età sono
rimasto orfano dovuto interrompere gli
studi mi sono dovuto trovare qualche
lavoro e quando ho ripreso gli studi
universitari
mi sono reso conto che c'era qualcosa
che non quadrava in quello che ci
dicevano sulla comunicazione dicevano
che alcune persone erano influenza bili
ed altre no
dicevano che le persone più capaci a
comunicare a capire la comunicazione
erano i medici gli psicologi
poi mi sono accorto che questo non era
vero
non era vero perché incredibilmente
conoscevo delle persone laureate in
scienze della comunicazione che io
ritenevo caspita uno che ha una laurea
in scienze della comunicazione sarà un
comunicatore straordinario in realtà non
lo era non lo era perché perché la
formazione universitaria una formazione
in cui studi delle informazioni le
memorizzi e poi le riferisci durante
durante l'esame
questa è una cosa che ripeto spesso
adesso che incredibilmente sono arrivato
addirittura ad insegnare all'università
insegno proprio la comunicazione
all'università la sapienza di roma
quindi spesso dico ai miei studenti
guardate che non basta possedere un
titolo per essere in grado di usare le
capacità le abilità le competenze che
chi a quel titolo dovrebbe avere quindi
un laureato in scienze della
comunicazione dovrebbe essere uno
straordinario comunicatore uno psicologo
dovrebbe essere uno straordinario
comunicatore uno straordinario
ascoltatore e uno straordinario
osservatore a me ho scoperto che non
sono tutti così ce ne sono anche ma
sviluppano queste altre capacità di
comunicazione queste altre competenze
studiandole a parte studiandole in corsi
privati quindi c'erano molte cose che
non mi quadra vano
ho scoperto per esempio che ci sono 54
gli ho poi ridotti motivi fondamentali
per i quali si può imparare a convincere
le persone a comunicare meglio si può
impreziosire se stessi non comprando
nulla semplicemente usando quello che la
natura ci ha donato ci ha dato ci ha
dato una voce ci ha dato il linguaggio e
ci ha dato il corpo e quindi il primo
motivo fondamentale per cui noi possiamo
migliorare possiamo convincere chiunque
sia che diciamo la verità sia che
diciamo
il falso il primo motivo è perché siamo
influenza b lì siamo influenza bili in
questa rappresentazione grafica
ho voluto mettere l'esempio più attuale
di influenzabilità di influenza di massa
le freak news che imperversano sui
social network soprattutto in questo
periodo pre elettorale
in realtà le fec news che cosa sono solo
delle bugie convincenti
quindi sono delle bugie che vengono
confezionate in modo da sembrare delle
verità sembrare delle notizie e delle
informazioni e quindi ecco qua un
esempio di come si può essere
convincenti pur non dicendo la verità
darò anche delle istruzioni per l'uso su
come si può essere convincenti
e ovvio che poi la scelta è di tipo
etico diventare convincenti per dire
solo la verità o diventare convincenti
per dire la verità vola menzogna quando
si vuole questo poi la scelta sta ognuno
di noi
il secondo motivo fondamentale mi sono
reso conto e che ci è data la libertà
di mentire ci è data la libertà di dire
cose diverse da quelle che pensiamo
sentiamo sappiamo e questo è un grande
dono cioè abbiamo la possibilità di
scegliere se dire ciò che pensiamo o se
dire che pensiamo qualcos'altro è anche
questo io l'ho trovato straordinario
ho trovato straordinario perché ripeto
c'era la libertà come aspetto che mi
interessava di più sul mentire
appunto ho anche scoperto che i
mentitori fai da te spesso non
funzionano perché mentono solo con le
parole
e quindi se chi ti ascolta è un
osservatore attento si accorgerà da come
parli o dall'espressione del volto che
hai piuttosto che dalla postura in cui
ti trovi che stai dicendo qualcosa che
il resto della tua comunicazione non
conferma
ovvero con le parole dici una cosa con
la voce con il corpo ne dice un'altra
l'esempio più lampante e quando noi
chiedi a qualcuno sei d'accordo con me
certamente e poi magari scuote la testa
senza rendersene conto
perché il corpo fa quello che vuole se
non è se non si è abituati a controllare
la comunicazione del corpo quindi
mentire è una libertà ecco qua che
arriviamo al mentire un po più evoluto
il mentire un po più evoluto è il finger
e gli attori sono dei mentitori molto
convincenti perché mentono e non mentono
ogni tanto mi piace anche scherzare
sulle regole di pronuncia della lingua
italiana
perché mentono e mentono con le parole
con la voce con il comportamento e
quindi sono credibili perché mandano lo
stesso messaggio con tutti i canali
della propria comunicazione quindi si
può diventare convincenti ma la mia
scoperta è stata che i più bravi
comunicatori sono gli attori e non sono
gli psicologi e non sono i medici e non
sono tante altre categorie che hanno la
reputazione di essere dei capaci
comunicatori o dei capaci osservatori
paradossalmente ho scoperto che migliori
osservatori ascoltatori sono proprio gli
attori perché essendo abituati ad
un'attenzione ad altri aspetti del
linguaggio che normalmente le persone
non curano si prendono cura anche di
come gli altri usano la voce quando
ascoltano ascoltano anche la voce della
persona non soltanto le parole che sta
dicendo è un po come facendo la
trasposizione quello spicco la speaker
che mi ha preceduto
una cosa e ascoltare le parole di una
canzone una cosa è ascoltare con esatta
attenzione sia la musica che le parole
della canzone vado ancora avanti
un'altra scoperta straordinaria e un po
disarmante che le persone non credono
soltanto alla verità ma credono a tutto
ciò che sembra loro essere vero ovvero
alle convinzioni e ho voluto sfruttare
il gioco di parole del termine in
inglese credere che believe
perché se ci fate caso al centro c'è la
parola lay line mentire tu l'hai e
mentire
quindi è come a dire che nelle
convinzioni in ciò a cui noi diamo molto
credito c'è sempre una bugia c'è sempre
qualcosa che non possiamo verificare il
rispetto a questo tema delle convinzioni
ovvero delle
simil verità chiamiamo le ho anche
scoperto che addirittura nel 1077 c'era
stato il cardinale l'arcivescovo di
canterbury tale anselmo d'aosta che
aveva scritto un libro in cui parlava di
un modello che voi vedete qui
rappresentato ma ovviamente da me
personalizzato di un modello che serviva
per testare se realmente esiste
esistessero dio e io questo modello l'ho
usato per esperienza ho consigliato di
utilizzarlo anche gli studenti per
testare la tenuta la resistenza delle
proprie convinzioni
quindi mi sono iniziato a chiedere ma
questa cosa che io ritengo essere vera
intanto è credibile e poi se è credibile
la posso dimostrare oppure no ecco poi
avendo studiato la comunicazione mi sono
reso conto che spesso le persone usavano
il significato di una parola in un altro
modo
quindi quando parlavano di dimostrare
non parlavano di offrire prove concrete
ma parlavano di fare dei ragionamenti
per avvalorare una tesi lo chiamavano
dimostrare invece io che venivo da un
mondo un po ho fatto tanti lavori ma
anche molto umili per me dimostrare
significava che se io avessi dovuto
dimostrare di saper costruire un muretto
con dei mattoni dimostrare significava
fare il muretto di mattoni non parlare
di come va fatto un muretto di mattoni
quindi dimostrare per me significava
questo è questo facendo una
trasposizione nella mia analisi ho detto
ok non lo posso dimostrare cioè non c'è
nulla di materiale che io possa mettere
su un tavolo per dimostrare che questa
cosa che io ritengo essere vera
lo sia non ho nulla e poi mi sono
chiesto se è dimostrabile è credibile o
è incredibile perché è credibile perché
è incredibile
talvolta per mancanza di conoscenze
vedete in questo quadrante che ho creato
in questo grafico ho messo nello spazio
ad esempio del dimostrabile incredibile
due esempi conosciuti il buco nero che
qualcosa che avrei una grande difficoltà
a spiegare ma che è stata ben spiegata
scientificamente e ha dell'incredibile
ha dell'incredibile perché rivoluziona
un po la visione che abbiamo noi delle
proporzioni delle dimensioni e poi
l'altra cosa che invece conosco bene
l'ipnosi l'ipnosi fino a qualche tempo
fa aveva la reputazione di essere magia
di essere qualcosa di esoterico di
essere qualcosa di misterioso in realtà
ho scoperto che se inizia a parlare più
lentamente le persone iniziano a
rallentare quindi l'ipnosi è
comunicazione semplicemente un modo
diverso di parlare di gesticolare di
dire qualcosa
la mia scoperta mi ha portato anche la
mia esplorazione a scoprire che ci sono
fondamentalmente tre errori quindi
abbiamo detto quattro motivi
fondamentali
tre errori attuali nel mondo della
persuasione quella professionale il
primo parlare solo dei vantaggi quando
vogliamo convincere qualcuno gli gli
parliamo oggi scriviamo questo avviene
anche sul web
soltanto di quale saranno i vantaggi che
otterrà se farà una certa cosa in realtà
l'uomo è mosso fondamentalmente da due
tipi di scelta vuole sapere cosa otterrà
come vantaggio ma anche che cosa gli
eviterà fare una certa scelta
quali rischi eviterò oltre a quali
vantaggi avrò se acquisterò la polizza
assicurativa che mi viene venduta
piuttosto che fare un'altra cosa
quindi un errore che ci porta a
considerare che gli altri si convincono
dallo stesso modo in cui noi ci
convinceremo se qualcuno ci facesse
quella proposta secondo errore
fondamentale parlare di cambiamento
molti messaggi pubblicitari molti
messaggi motivazionali molta formazione
che si fa nelle aziende parla di
cambiamento change e questo cambiamento
nella cultura italiana porta a un detto
popolare che dice chi lascia la strada
vecchia per quella nuova sa quello che
lascia ma non sa quello che trova
e quindi destabilizza chi lo avverte la
mia proposta sarebbe al posto di
cambiamento parlare di miglioramento per
evitare che qualcuno cambiamento può
significare sia in peggio che in meglio
il terzo attuale errore di persuasione è
appunto quello di confondere il
significato con l'effetto confondere ciò
che vorrei trasmettere con ciò che in
realtà trasmetterò nella mia esperienza
non conosco neanche una persona che
abbia smesso di fumare dopo aver letto
questa frase sul pacchetto delle
sigarette
quindi questo è il classico esempio di
errore di persuasione il messaggio che
mandi deve produrre un effetto
purtroppo anche scolasticamente
culturalmente siamo abituati a ritenere
che il significato equivalga all'effetto
e vado a concludere come vedete qua c'è
un esempio lampante di errore di
comunicazione
un tizio che si chiama romano che fa il
saluto con la mano destra e questa foto
è stata utilizzata è ampiamente
pubblicizzata e addirittura elogiata
hanno elogiato il fotografo hanno
elogiato l'agenzia di comunicazione è un
errore madornale saluto romano romano fa
il saluto con la mano destra e non mi
pare fosse politicamente collocato
da quella parte un altro esempio molto
lampante vado a concludere che spesso
noi parliamo agli altri
ritenendo che quello che interessa noi
interessa anche loro ma questo non è
affatto vero
tra i rimedi anti persuasione il primo
che cosa vedete in questa immagine
l'avete il cane l'avete visto che c'è un
cane nell'immagine c'è un cane è lì
nella macchina e quindi questo per dire
che bisogna stare attenti il primo
rimedio anti persuasione e diventare più
attenti alle cose a cui non fate caso
quindi istruzione per l'uso molto veloce
iniziate a stare attenti a che cosa vi è
sfuggito non sa che cosa avete notato
che gratifica di più
il secondo rimedio purtroppo è
definitivo se non vuoi essere persuaso
c'è una un'unica condizione in cui
nessuno tipo persuadere ed è quella lì
c'è un solo modo per diventare
convincenti nella comunicazione che è la
mia passione la mia passione che mi ha
permesso di raggiungere obiettivi che
ritenevano non fossero alla alla mia
altezza e l'unico modo è imparare ad
usare meglio quello che la natura ci ha
dato
imparare a scoprire cos'altro dobbiamo
imparare sulle parole cos'altro dobbiamo
imparare su come utilizzare uno
strumento portentoso che è la voce è
ancora uno come usare il linguaggio del
corpo e concludo con una riflessione che
per me è determinante
qualsiasi cosa noi sappiamo a una
utilità se la applichiamo tant'è vero
che un detto della papua nuova guinea
dice proprio questo qua grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]